we all knew that Batman Arkham Knight
has been in a sorry state on PC since
day one that's been largely evident
through the mostly negative user rating
the game the sporting on steam now
Warner Brothers have decided to suspend
all pc sales until the game is fixed
Warner Brothers have opted to cease
future sales of Arkham Knight on PC
until the game is fixed a statement has
been posted to the official forums
apologizing for the game's performance
issues adding quote we take these issues
very seriously and have therefore
decided to suspend future game sales of
the pc version while we work to address
these issues to satisfy our quality
standards Warner Brothers have
encouraged gamers to continue providing
feedback of their experiences and issues
the publisher have also signed posted
where gamers can request a refund on
Steam should they desire one let me know
down in the comments if you think this
is the right move by Warner Brothers or
not and why we'll be keeping you updated
as this one develops so be sure to stay
tuned to gamespot
you